my wife and I would I would walk in the
door and this sounds cruel and I'm going
to get a bunch of mean emails I don't
care I'd walk past my
kids I'd say hi guys hi guys and I'd go
straight to Mom and Mom got my first hug
mom got my first
attention and then we would always say I
would say hi to the kids and then I
would say we have to have we're having
adult time y'all got to go and they had
to leave the
room and they have learned that even we
say we're having an adult talk they walk
they they'll just get up and leave
because it's just so wired into them
that they just know that's a part of our
home that they come second to my
marriage the kids have to come second to
your
marriage and in a strange way they they
will go in their rooms and they'll play
and they'll do silly things and yes
they'll whine and complain he hit me BL
cool as soon as we're done with with
with uh mom with adult time then we'll
we'll come back